welcome to the presentation on graphing
lines let's let's get started so let's
say I had the equation let me make sure
that this line doesn't show up too thick
let's say I had the equation oh why is
it showing up let's see oh they're
integral Y is equal to 2x plus 1 so this
is giving a relationship between x and y
so if say x equals 1 then Y would be 2
times 1 plus 1 or 3 so for every X that
that we can think of we can think of a
corresponding Y so let's do that if we
said that table here x and y and let's
just throw out some random numbers for X
if X was let's say negative 1 then Y
would be 2 times negative 1 which is
negative 2 plus 1 which would be
negative 1 if X was 0 that's easy
it'd be 2 times 0 which is 0 plus 1
which is 1 if X was 1 Y would be 2 times
1 which is 2 plus 1 which is 3 if X was
2 then I think you get the idea here y
would be 5 and we could keep on going
and get obviously there are an infinite
number of X's we could choose and it
could pick a corresponding Y so now you
see we have a little table that gives
the relationships between x and y what
we can do now is actually graph those
points on a coordinate axis so let me
see if I can draw this somewhat neatly
I'll use this line tool so I get
straight lines ok
that's pretty good okay now let me draw
some coordinate points so let's say
that's that's one that's two that's
three this is negative one negative two
negative three so this is the x-axis if
we have one two three and as you can
keep going one two three and this is the
y-axis Y and this would be one two three
and so on this is a negative one I think
you get the idea so we can graph each of
these points so if we have the point X
is negative 1 Y is negative one so X we
go along the x axis here and we go to X
is equal to negative one and then we go
to Y is equal to negative one so the
point would be right here
I hope that makes sense to you that's
the point
I'll label it negative one comma
negative one it's a little messy that
says negative 1 comma negative 1 that
point I just X right there let's do
another one and this that's this point
I'll do it in a different color this
time let's say we had the point 0 comma
1 well X is 0 which is here and Y is 1
so that point is right there let's do
one more if we have the point 1 comma 3
well 1 comma 3 X is 1 and we have Y is 3
so we have the point right there hope
that's making sense for you and we could
keep graphing them but I think you see
here and especially if I had drawn this
a little bit neater that these points
are forming a line let me let me draw
that line in I don't the line looks
something like this
actually that's not a good line let me
do it better than that
the line looks something like this
you see that eight well that's actually
a pretty bad line that I just drew so
but it would be a line that goes through
let me change tools it'd be a line that
goes through here through here and
through here me I don't know if I'm
making this clear at all let me make
these points a little bit you see the
line will go through all of these points
they'll also go through the point 2
comma 5 which will be up here someplace
and any point for any X that you can
think of if you had X is equal to 10
billion 380 the corresponding Y will
also be on this line so this pink line
and it keeps going on forever that
represents every possible combination of
X's and Y's that will satisfy this
equation and of course X doesn't have to
just be whole numbers or integers X
could be X could be pi 3.14159 in which
case would be someplace here and then in
which case you would have Y would be 2
pi plus 1 so every number that X could
be there's a corresponding Y let's do
another one so if I had the equation y
is equal to that's ugly y Y is equal to
negative 3x plus 5 well let's just I'm
going to draw a quick and dirty this
time so that's the x-axis that's the
y-axis let's put some values here so x
and y so x is say if X is negative 1 the
negative 1 times negative 3 is 3 plus y
that's 8 if X is zero then Y is 5 that's
pretty easy if X is 1 negative 3 times 1
is negative 3 then Y is 2 if X is 2
negative 3 times 2 is negative 6 then Y
is 1 is that right negative 6
no no negative 1 maybe something was
wrong
there right so let's graph some of these
points so when X is negative one and I'm
just kind of approximating when X is
negative 1 Y is negative 8 so that point
will be someplace around here and
there's a whole module on graphing
coordinates if you finding the graph the
graphing a coordinate pair to be a
little confusing when X is a 8 I just
made a mistake when X is negative 1 Y is
8 not negative 8 so ignore this right
here when X is negative 1 Y is positive
8
so Y do that pier someplace when x is 0
Y is 5 so it'd be here someplace when X
is 1 Y is 2 like here when X is 2 y is
negative 1 so as you can see and I've
approximated if I had graphing paper if
I had a better drawn chart I could have
you could have seen it it would have
been exactly right
I think this line will do the job that
every point on this that satisfies this
equation actually falls on this line and
something interesting here I'll point
out you notice that this line it slopes
downwards it goes from the top left to
the bottom right while the line we had
drawn before had gone from the bottom
left to the top right is there anything
about this equation that that seems a
little bit different than the last I'll
give you a little bit of a hint this
number the negative 3 or you could say
that that's the coefficient on X that
determines whether this whether the line
slopes upward whether the line slopes
downward and tells you also how steep
the line is and that actually negative 3
is a slope and I'm going to do a whole
other module on slope and this number
here is called the y-intercept and that
actually tells you where you're going to
intersect the y-axis and it turns out
here that you intersect the axis at 0
comma 5 let's do one more real fast
why is equal to two and now we're ready
to 2x y is equal to one-half X plus two
so real fast
X Y let's say and you only need two
points for a line really so you could
just say let's say x equals zero that's
easy y equals two and if x equals 2 then
y equals three so before when we were
doing three and four points that was
just to kind of show you but you really
just need two points for line so zero
comma one two so that's on there and
then 1 2 comma 3 since there so the line
is going to look something like this
so notice here once again we're
upward-sloping and that's because this
1/2 is positive but we're not sloping
we're not moving up as quickly as when
we had y equals 2x y equals 2x looks
something like this
sloping up much much much faster hope
I'm not confusing you and then the
y-intercept of course is at 0 comma 2
which is right here so if you ever want
to graph a line it's real easy you just
have to graph some you have to just try
out some points and you can graph it and
now the next module I'm going to show
you a little bit more about slope and
y-intercept and you won't even have to
do this but this gives you good
intuitive feel of I think what a graph
of a line is I hope you have fun